- [Voiceover] I think
it was Macbeth who said,
"If music be the spice
of life, then I love it!"
Shoot.
Either way, my allowance
of employees to listen
to reasonably volumed
music means productivity
in the workplace has never been greater!
(driving hiphop)
- [Voiceover] Yeah, get it!
Damn, Drake, you done it again!
I'm invincible with you by my side.
Just stay away from that
Nicki Minaj, though, okay?
She's a bad influence on you, Bae.
- [Voiceover] Take me from here,
(New Age vocalizing)
"Soundscapes", by Lana Fried!
Oh, I'm so much more productive
when I picture myself
in a Bengalese jungle, being waited on
hand and foot by day laborers.
This is the life!
- [Voiceover] Have the keys
always been this close together?
(dance music)
I'm thirsty.
I'm doing good work today.
Do I use my pinky or my ring finger less?
This is good work.
Coffee is good.
Work is good. Things are good.
Good working today, Anna.
Good working!
(musical variety)
- [Voiceover] Yes!
Yes, more music!
Coachella is happening in my cubicle!
Who's not cool enough
to get in a frat, now?
- [Voiceover] Finally.
It takes me putting on broken earbuds
for these clowns to leave me alone.
- Hey, did you hear the new...
- [Voiceover] You're too thirsty, office.
Too thirsty.
- [Voiceover] Yes, music is
vital to our productivity.
As for me, I don't need
to listen to music.
It lives within me.
I'm filled to the brim with it!
And I have been, ever since starring
as Harold Hill in a gender-bent version
of Meredith Willson's "The Music Man"!
♫ We are in trouble, little guy
♫ Right here, I say, trouble
right here in Creek Township
♫ Why, I always had a tennis racket
♫ Always had a tennis racket
♫ Always had some trouble with it
♫ Do you say trouble, I say trouble
♫ Trouble, yes, trouble, no
- Does anyone else listen to music
(frenzied singing continues)
just to drown out Natalie?
- ♫ Trouble, trouble, trouble
- Yes.
- [Voiceover] She sounds like my grandma.
My grandma with asthma?
- ♫ Everyone likes trouble
Ah, except us!